I think what we're wondering is if you
have a girl here and why last week on
Keeping Up with the Kardashians we saw
the family accused Scott Disick of
flying a girl out to Costa Rica during
their family vacation on Sunday's
episode we saw how that drama played out
obviously like I did something wrong as
always like well this you flew someone
out of the country that is so
disrespectful every night you go to bed
with our kids and I have to sleep alone
sad and miserable that's my life then
things got even more heated after Scott
made this explosive statement so let me
you then I wanted to do like this yeah
here you go
no I'm a sex addict yeah that
conversation ended with Khloe throwing a
drink then Kim then Kris but in typical
Scott fashion he diffused the awkward
situation with humor all right so should
we head on together no you and me later
we saw more of Kourtney and Scott's
complicated relationship unfold here's
what they ultimately decided you're
stuck at Mario don't know not to pretend
you think the world is the story and we
are
[Music]